louis ar se mencionó el rumbo que tomara
bolivia bajo su mando el heredero del ex
presidente evo morales fue consultado
sobre uno de los temas que más causa
curiosidad tendrá el exmandatario un rol
dentro de su gobierno hacer lo descartó
y se limitó a decir que morales podrá
volver al país cuando quiera
en ningún bowl ya no se puede distinguir
que entre al país pero en el gobierno yo
tengo que decir bajo el gobierno
interino de jeanine áñez bolivia rompió
relaciones con cuba y venezuela a raíz
de las tensiones provocadas por las
fallidas elecciones del año pasado y la
renuncia y el posterior exilio del ex
presidente morales ahora arse se mostró
dispuesto a reanudar estos lazos con dos
de sus antiguos aliados latinoamericanos
nos vamos a abrir después a todos los
países el único requisito es que los
países nos respeten y respeten nuestra
soberanía
[Música]
su llegada al poder también representa
un alivio para los ex ministros de
morales que se refugiaron en la embajada
mexicana el año pasado para evitar ser
arrestados arze dijo que les otorgaría
el salvoconducto que han solicitado para
poder salir del país
los votos en los comicios de bolivia
todavía esperan su recuento final pero
arce ya es reconocido como el ganador el
virtual presidente propone además un
gobierno renovado en el país y una
reconciliación con la oposición en medio
de las tensiones latentes entre ambos
sectores a raíz de las fallidas
elecciones de 2019